[Music]
good morning everyone it's day three of
staying at home yeah right you're like
the one that loves being inside the most
I don't know three of us should appear
in this house I've been one that hasn't
gone out the most you're right yeah I
think we switch spot in terms of who's
more introverted true I think I beat you
now doesn't flow that's not like this so
I think Ted and flowin and now I'm now
I'm going towards see I want to go out
there to the world
that's the Cremona Carson City yeah
you're like and I'm like I'm good okay
and I could just be like this and not
shower ever know I feel gross I need a
shower I feel even more gross when you
do this even though I know it's really
sweet but I just makes me hyper aware of
my smell it's this sense of home and I
really have no excuse for not showering
because I've been at home today I'm
gonna shower I promise guy but I wanted
to talk to you guys so we just made some
coffee you know I was saying that and we
usually use the reusable cup because I
always feel really guilty using the K
Cups and then creating more waste well
since we're home I'm like okay let's not
use the K Cups totally got time to use a
reusable cup guess what it doesn't fit
in this fridge in the in the new
refrigerator thingamajiggy it doesn't
actually fit so now we've been doing
like some research on the computers we
were looking at like where can we find a
reusable cup that fits our specific
model because this is the single-serve
brew and then we were reading some
forums and then people are like she
should be ashamed of themselves for not
offering a reusable cup so that means
we've been using the k-cup so let me
show you
we're gonna try and customize our
reusable thing and drill a hole and like
trying to seal it and make it I take
this thing out and then you open that
see this is where you put the cake up
right okay so then here is the reusable
filter that we own that we've been using
with that coffeemaker
but for that coffeemaker we need this
adapter once we open this we put the
filter inside the adapter and then this
whole thing goes into that that's how
this works and we tried other filters
and this one was the best because it
didn't make it super watery because
other filters make the coffee really
really watery but this one's been great
now that we have this new thing in my
bobber the puncture needle is down there
which means we cannot use like this is
way too big to put into this thing so we
have to use the filter itself but this
filter does not have a hole underneath
it so we were thinking of drilling a
hole in here just to force it so I could
like make sure that it could fit if we
can't find a filter that is meant for
this specific model so yeah we're gonna
try to do some experiments we also
looked online and we saw like some metal
metal kind of filters that seemed to
have like a little groove here at the
bottom where maybe this punker needle
didn't like kind of hi I don't know
we're gonna figure it out but I really
do not want to be wasting a whole bunch
of k-cups
I want to use this thing yeah yeah I
mean at least do a tiny little part but
that's the current situation with this
bang seat so let me show you if we try
to put it in here and then we try to
close it it does not close but another
real fear we have is if we do drill a
hole will it make the coffee extra water
you because now there's there's more
water running through it we will not
know one thing I don't understand
one that just has a hole at the bottom
and not this mesh on the side is that
the plastic cake couplers which I think
generally most people agree the plastic
k-cups that runners are more delicious
than ones because it's not so watery yes
it's quite the predicament here from
what coffee
Keurig users yeah I don't know why they
just want to make one that is exactly
how the plastic ones work where you have
a hole at the bottom yeah all of the
reusable ones have a mesh no so I'm like
is this is this a sign that we need to
invent our own just kidding
I mean I have a lot of ideas I'm just
not a doer so yeah I don't know
tell Mike sure he's just screwed figure
out how to drill a hole but yeah like
the whole watery thing is is a real
issue we don't want it to be too watery
because like I said we tried other
filters and the other ones like the tiny
little mesh holes they were a lot bigger
which made the coffee a lot more water
ears pretty good yeah this is a good one
but yeah that's our current predicament
see what happens when you're at home you
got nothing to do oh by the way this
morning this guy he fixed our bidet
problem so the you know how last night
it was leaking and it was going all over
the place so he went back to Home Depot
and he got plumbers tape and then he
used plumber's tape and that solved the
problem so now we have a bidet but let
me go show you how ridiculous it looks
because we don't have an outlet in the
bathroom so we can't to use an extension
cord he's got it hooked up it's not
leaking anymore yeh but then look at
this we have to connect it to our closet
so that was one of many projects around
the house that has been semi complete
because we're gonna get an electrician
eventually to come and put an outlet in
this area once we've removed this so we
can have a TV here and at the same time
we're gonna have them put an outlet by
the toilet
breath I'm really out of shape which you
up to my boy
you look so comfortable oh and there's
no internet yeah I like playing that -
what's your high score ooh nice
mine's like 3000 something I don't have
it that's why that game pops up which is
a little hack in case you guys didn't
know I remember you taught me that a
long time yeah right yeah yeah finally I
get credit for something I taught you
usually you forget I teach you things no
I'm actually long daddy taught me oh no
don't do that to me again
but mama yeah yeah Gary and Diana are on
their way sweetie like 30 minutes yeah
they're gonna be here soon oh yeah I got
a shower too but yeah that's just a
little insight into every morning on day
three of being at home
yeah the Chan clan is coming all right
so take a shower but I think my parents
pulled up hey hi this is Don yeah
[Music]
[Music]
whoa full house this is the liveliest
our houses that has been no yeah what
are we doing now we're exploring our
little tot luck that we have on the
property the community so then they get
to look true very true very true
all this pig kids I know the only child
we do have to use right back oh cool
you're riding your your thingy majiggy
yeah Toit I use this as a workout oh
yeah there's everybody could do it stuff
you can do yeah you can do dips yeah I
was like wait I was like wait the two
young ones like wait who's that so my
parent just got in and my brother just
got in and this girlfriend's family just
got in and we're having a big reunion at
our house is their first time we're
having guests at our house and pretty
cool our house has never felt this
lively well and I've actually never been
over here to play on this Tot Lot that
we have installed in our neighborhood so
we're breaking it in pretty pretty fun
bouncy all right all right show me like
this booty
[Music]
[Laughter]
I want to play y'all play yeah let's do
it
yeah I wish it was longer oh there's the
pull-up bar all right so while everyone
else is taking a walk around the
neighborhood we decided to come back and
buy us helping us melt the TV yay I'd
remember if I bought this but last night
we were trying to find the stud with the
stud finder that Casey announced to go
by and then we just were having
difficulties because as soon as it would
beep and we'd be like cool we found this
stud if we mark it and then we go back
and then it wouldn't be penny more so
really
Oh what the heck man we can't rely on
this stud finder but yeah but then
Baba's able to figure it out after this
really good apparently it's really good
it was a user error we just didn't know
how to how to get it in line oh it's
better than urea hi my father he asked
me oh you did he was like all right I'm
gonna help you solve it today so I'm
gonna help you read you all the
electrical we're gonna do it today this
time
look at him he's drilling away that's so
sweet thank you we appreciate this but
for the record yes but you were telling
me that I started leaking so maybe he
doesn't really take a look at it
yeah I'm so glad we met here because
just between the two of us like I'm
pretty handy but yeah I need help okay
keep learning
it's so cute for some reason it's just
something looks like me that's my man I
had to be a handyman
I feel wearing this way more often it's
coffee I don't know why it's working
this is working for me I'll probably
take this off for now or at least like
put it backwards or something but then
you might put someone behind you I feel
like you don't know how the construction
stuff like ELISA there whoa like from a
third person oh yeah you know it's like
oh my god I see a disaster coming you
know are these your tools or did Katie
buddy's these artists hold
[Music]
that all right so daddy's vacuuming yeah
and moms working yep yep
[Music]
what unites it coming along
we're done with the wall part now you
have to yeah
[Music]
look at it look at the full motion yeah
and then we could be over here I love
you and then oh thank my boy
[Music]